vous me dites les allemands ont baissé
leur consommation de charbon c'est faux
les allemands en 2019 consommer plus de
charbon en 2009 est d'ailleurs sous le
mandat des maires pour les informer sur
on va le vérifier de vous le dire dans
un sourire amusé les fans si vous savez
les courbes sont rangés google en ruines
a multiplié en france ce qui était mon a
multiplié par deux la consommation
mérite français n'en sommes pas encore
là au petit poucet barbe d or la
consommation de charbon gaz charbon vous
le savez très bien c'est terriblement
mauvais pour le climat est pour vous le
savez bien alors le modèle que vous
proposez est un modèle qui en réalité
créé une dépendance aux centrales à gaz
et une dépendance aux centrales à
charbon nonobstant la laideur de ce que
vous proposez parce que je crois que
vous avez proposé deux mille cinq cents
éoliennes
c'est pas la moitié d'ailleurs de la
puissance des réacteurs que vous vous
les enlevez ce sens c'est pas la
démonter c'est pas la moitié de la
puissance des réacteurs que vous voulez
supprimer par ailleurs donc ça c'est pas
connu deux montées je sais pas comment
on va faire vous voulez b monte laissez
moi juste terminée s'est terminée par
une scène de
claire j'ai l'habitude de l'être et vous
voulez remplacer dès les éoliennes
actuelles par des éoliennes qui font 200
mètres de haut la tour montparnasse un
partout la tour montparnasse non mais
j'ai ri à un moment donné quand on se
dit défenseur de l'environnement de
l'écologie je suis navré de vous dire
que les éoliennes de 100 mètres de haut
avec les conséquences que ça sur la
santé humaine sur les animaux les
oiseaux voiture oui oui bien sûr sur les
courants quand elles sont offshore sur
les activités des pêcheurs eh bien ça me
paraît pas raisonnable au delà du fait
que ça nous créé une dépendance que
c'est le visionnement affreux le vent
lui laisser le vent l'effrayant que
c'est effrayant encore une fois pour la
protection de l'environnement c'est un
mauvais choix et l'animal et nous montre
que c'est un mauvais choix donc si vous
avez vous été le mauvais vous n'avez pas
de problème avec les cent mille pilotes
de ligne tht ça de très haute tension ça
vous trouvé ça très beau dans le paysage
vous n'avez je ne vous ai jamais
entendus
pour le prix cité du tout non mais
savait alors qu'ils n'ont alors
peut-être vous connaissez peut-être pas
très bien ce sujet mais en fait quand
vous relier des énergies renouvelables
vous n'avez pas de besoin de lignes à
très haute tension ça c'est pour les
réacteurs nucléaire ou les centrales
elle a coûté 100 milliards non non le
raccordement non mais les énergies
madame le pen intermittente sur le prix
vous n'y arriverez pas il ya un ep 1 qui
est en construction il écoute déjà 20
milliards il devait coûter 3 milliards
et je suis surpris vous qui parlez
toujours d'exemplarité en termes de
politiques publiques
je ne vous ai jamais entendu dire que
les responsables nucléaires devaient
rendent des comptes pour 17 milliards
d'euros de gabegie de gaspillage de
surcoûts dix ans de délai pour un ep r
est ce que vous proposez c'est de
transformer ainsi un fiasco en 6 8 au 14
fiasco comme emmanuel macron pour une
électricité pénates en 2005 anglais sur
les centrales à charbon oui ce que j'ai
quand même une équipe qui travaille en
régie mais ainsi va longtemps sur les
centrales à charbon ça a très légèrement
augmenté très légèrement mais ça n'a pas
d'oubli voilà non là qu'un canal où vous
regardez regardez la cour
vous regardez ces dernières années vous
regardez sur le charbon je veux dire
allez allez sur google regardez mix
énergétique alors albert est menée sur
la malle d'assurance j'ai dit qu'ils ont
construit surtout en allemagne en deux
en 2019 art de vivre lui sur 2010 9 6
pour 2010 atteint en 2009 mais sa hausse
a même pas de raison que ça avait doublé
mais lorsque j'ai dit en france annonce
en allemagne ça ne passe plus en 2014 et
en france alors c'est pas énorme mais
quand même ça a doublé donc on voit bien
on le sait très bien d'ailleurs qui
aiment gelés pendant ce encore une fois
au charbon et au gaz avec les énergies
est ajustable